il faut pas oublier que dans le
renseignement l'intelligence humaine est
un facteur condos qu'elle ne peut pas
échapper et vous avez encore
régulièrement en france c'est la
question concerne la france des loupes
et monumentaux avec des gens par exemple
qui sont mis en examen pour des dossiers
dans des dossiers de terroristes et qui
sortent de prison parce qu'il se remet
en liberté ou parce qu'ils ont une peine
qui arrive à échéance qui normalement
devraient être signalés à la dg ainsi
que la sécurité intérieure parce que le
renseignement pays de serres passe le
relais à la dgsi donc là j'ai vraiment
très simple c'est pas des trucs de la
mort qui tue c'est vraiment une fiche
est de quelqu'un qui sort de prison de
données d'un service renseignement un
autre et on se rend compte régulièrement
que la dgsi n'est pas au courant que ces
gens sont sortis de prison ça n'arrive
pas à chaque fois mais ça arrive plus
souvent qu'on ne le croit donc pour des
choses aussi simples
on a parfois du mal donc je pense que le
jour où un gouvernement en france sera
en capacité de savoir exactement en se
posant la question de savoir tiens vous
tient ce monsieur il a dit du mal de moi
à la télé la semaine dernière où
était-il exactement ces trois d un
arsenal qui a vu avant lui ni sa
modestie vous avez absolument du domaine
du fantasme
si jamais si jamais un gouvernement
décidé de mettre les moyens pour être
capables de faire ce genre de choses
d'abord ça se saurait parce que des gens
dans la chaîne mise en place mon frère
parlerait est très choqué il n'y a pas
100 % que fasciste chez les
fonctionnaires qui s'occupe de ces
sujets premièrement et deuxièmement ça
occuperait à ce point les gens chargés
de la sécurité que très vite il ne
pourrait pas s'occuper du reste donc est
ce que le risque théorique existe sans
doute que oui et je vais pas les
capacités techniques pour rentrer dans
le détail mais pour parler vraiment au
quotidien de ces sujets avec les gens
qui s'occupent de ces questions et en
particulier qui s'occupe de la question
de l'analyse qui est le sujet principal
je vous le dis très simplement sané en
pratique pas possible même aux états
unis qui sont beaucoup plus avancés que
nous sur ces questions les américains ne
sont pas en capacité de faire ça et
pourtant on dit que la haine essais et
peut intercepter à peu à peu près
n'importe quel propos sur la planète
donc je pense que cet avantage
[Musique]